Prof: Okay,
so I want to continue the story
about cleaning up landscapes
that have been severely
affected.
And I wanted to use this as a
basis for reviewing a variety of
different laws that apply and
certain key provisions in the
statutes that have met with more
or less success.
And I'm going to start today
with the National Environmental
Policy Act, which was passed in
late 1969.
And it was one of the first
statutes that declared a
comprehensive national policy to
protect the environment.
And I wanted to just pause on
this, because many people think
that the idea of sustainability
is fairly new.
But if you look at the purpose
statement inside this statute,
you see that back in the late
1960s that many of the ideals
that people now believe and
think of when they use the
phrase sustainability are deeply
embedded in this statute.
So let me just go through this
quickly.
"The Congress,
recognizing the profound impact
of man's activity on the
interrelations of all components
of the natural environment,
particularly the profound
influences of population growth,
high-density urbanization,
industrial expansion,
resource exploitation,
and new and expanding
technological advances,
and recognizing further the
critical importance of restoring
and maintaining environmental
quality to the overall welfare
and development of man,
declares that it is the
continuing policy of the federal
government,
in cooperation with state and
local governments and other
concerned public and private
organizations,
to use all practicable means
and measures,
including financial and
technical assistance in a manner
calculated to foster and promote
the general welfare.
To create and maintain
conditions under which man and
nature can exist in productive
harmony and fulfill the social,
economic, and other
requirements of present and
future generations of
Americans."
This is an exceptionally broad
mission statement.
This law was passed,
not with any regulatory
authority, so it could not
prevent human development.
But it demanded instead that
any project,
private or federal,
that would receive public funds
from the Federal Treasury,
would be required to declare
exactly what the proposed
development was and to project
out what the environmental
effects might be into the
future.
The statute was also curious in
that it included something
called a citizen suit provision.
So that environmental groups or
other citizen watchdog groups
could monitor federal agencies,
they could look at their budget
and think about what kinds of
development were being proposed
by Congress,
contained in authorization
statutes or appropriations,
and then think down the road
about how to make sure that
those developments proceeded in
a way that had a minimal impact
on the environment.
So this was the origin of the
idea of an environmental impact
statement,
a model for declaring and
basically making public all
proposals for new development.
And also, it created an
enormous industry in the
environmental sciences,
an industry that really
involved soil scientists,
atmospheric chemists,
water quality experts that all
joined together to try to figure
out exactly what the effects of
new development might be.
Now, if you think about the
scale of our economy and you
think about the federal budget
and you realize that just this
past week our president issued
his proposed budget,
almost $3 trillion.
That's an enormous amount of
money being expended that would
be put into projects developed
by the Defense Department,
the Energy Department,
the Department of
Transportation and Highways.
Even the Environmental
Protection Agency,
when they issue a permit now to
a new sewage treatment plant or
a new water supply facility,
that treatment plant must be
reviewed in the context of an
environmental impact statement.
So that any expenditure of
funds demands that this
forward-looking projection
occur,
and it's always open to citizen
suit,
citizen contest through
litigation.
And it's been very effective in
altering new development.
Many dams have been stopped by
this statute,
by judges' interpretation of
it, because of claims of
insufficiency of the
environmental impact statements.
So that it also includes a very
extensive public hearing process
whereby drafts have to be
prepared.
They have to be taken to public
hearing,
people have to have an
opportunity to review the
material so that they can
understand what might be
happening in their backyard.
And they may also be very
critical of the quality of
science.
And this is not laboratory
science, this is science that
really is predictive in nature.
It's probabilistic in a sense.
So most environmental science
that demands forecasting,
you should think about it as
being probabilistic,
which is why most programs in
environmental studies have a
requirement for taking
statistics and often
probability.
So the scientists needed to
look into the past and try to
discern from previous studies
what was most likely to happen
in the future.
And the only way that a project
could be stopped would be if the
impact statement were found to
be insufficient,
to not fully have disclosed
what the effects would be or to
include science that really was
poorly done,
that did not seem defensible.
So I'm going to move on to
discuss several other statutes
now.
But one key point is that
citizen suit provisions have
been built into a variety of
major environmental laws,
including the Clean Air Act,
the Clean Water Act,
CERCLA, which is the Superfund
law,
the Resource Conservation and
Recovery Act,
the cradle-to-grave statute
that I mentioned the other day,
the Emergency Planning and
Community Right to Know Act,
which gives communities the
right to know what chemicals are
being released in their
environments if those chemicals
are recognized to be hazardous
substances,
and the Endangered Species Act.
So basically,
this opportunity for litigation
has really radically changed the
way that new development and
uses of the environment have
gone forward.
Now in this case,
in the case that we talked
about on Tuesday,
hazardous site on Vieques in
Puerto Rico,
this was a very important
statute in that the court case,
Romero-Barcelo v.
Weinberger,
or Weinberger v.
Romero-Barcelo,
was brought in part because the
Navy had not developed an
environmental impact statement
that projected out what the
long-term effects might be of
their continued bombing of the
island.
So this statute required-- was
interpreted by a judge in Puerto
Rico to require the development
of a draft environmental impact
statement,
which was prepared.
It's kind of curious,
because I wanted to find that
draft environmental impact
statement.
I didn't know whether or not
there might be projections of
long-term damage or perhaps
accounting of kinds of weapons
that had been released.
So I looked for it and in Mudd
Library,
the former government documents
library here,
we had and we still have many
environmental impact statements
that you can request.
Unfortunately,
you can't wander through the
aisles anymore because it's been
closed down.
But the university still
maintains these environmental
impact statements that are
actually quite interesting to
browse through.
Well, I couldn't find this
impact statement.
And then our social science
librarian put out a message on
her email list and asked if
anybody in the nation might have
a copy of this.
And it turned out that one
person on this list of all
university libraries and public
libraries responded yes,
that he had collected all
military draft environmental
impact statements,
including this one.
So he Xeroxed it and sent it to
me.
It turned out to be a goldmine
in that it demonstrated a
variety of historical action on
the part of the Navy,
including diagrams such as
this.
You see the bombing range up
here on the upper left,
but you also see in basically
the same scale,
other maps that the Navy put
together showing where their
targets were,
showing also color codings of
these areas,
in this case,
concentric circles,
that had the metric and the key
number of bombs dropped or
pounds of bombs dropped per acre
per year.
So this proved to be really
important, to try to think
through what was released,
when it was released,
and where it might have gone.
And one interesting thing is
that you see that this side of
the bay over here looks like it
was continually targeted.
In fact, tanks were located at
the top of hills,
and they were clearly being
targeted, both by bombers but
also by artillery shells.
So gradually,
this area, this part of the
landscape, was being flattened.
And by flattening the beach
area at the end of that runway,
they basically created a
trough, a trough by which that
lagoon could drain all of the
material that it had collected
into the bay.
And also, I looked at this air
photograph maybe thirty or forty
times and it hadn't dawned on me
that this little light patch
right here seemed like it was
just an open area of sand.
But you can track it on Google
Earth and find that it reaches
down gradually and then fades
into sea grass beds.
But clearly,
it's evidence that material has
flowed out of that area and
killed the vegetation on the
floor of this bay.
The same thing happened on the
other site.
And if you see these lines in
the diagram down here,
these lines depict the bombing
route, so that planes would take
off from aircraft carriers.
They would fly up in this
direction on the east side.
They'd circle around and come
back and fly back this way and
bomb in both directions.
So three or four fighter planes
would be doing this continually,
year after year,
decade after decade,
millions of pounds after
millions of pounds,
so that they disclosed not just
pounds per acre per year,
but total amount of munitions
so that the estimate of 100 to
150 million pounds of ordinance
is basically derived from
information that was provided in
the environmental impact
statement that would not
otherwise have been made
available.
Since that time,
I've recognized also that the
Navy has maintained a really
tough and tight accounting
system of what they did.
And how would I know that?
Well, by talking to people that
were ordinance officers.
And you recall those large
concrete bunkers,
couple hundred concrete bunkers
up in the hills loaded with
different kinds of weapons?
Well, they were officers or
enlisted men that were
responsible for the inventory in
each of the buildings.
I mean, they want to know how
many nuclear weapons they've got
and where they are at any point
in time.
So they had kept their records
very neatly.
Again, this information was not
included in the environmental
impact statement,
but it provided a basis for
litigation.
So that this type of historical
documentation is often very
difficult to come by.
Another statute that has played
an important role here and in
many hazardous sites around the
nation,
is the Resource Conservation
and Recovery Act of 1976,
which was designed to manage
both hazardous and nonhazardous
waste,
and included the
cradle-to-grave tracking system,
meaning that wastes or
hazardous chemicals from their
time of creation,
their movement via ship or by
rail or by tanker truck,
and their ultimate disposal had
to be recorded.
So it was a large-scale
national inventory system.
And the key to this system,
just the Endangered Species Act
that I was talking about the
other day or the Safe Drinking
Water Act,
the core of the system and its
Achilles' heel,
is really that the chemical has
to be listed as a hazardous
substance to make its way onto
the list.
So you can imagine that adding
additional chemicals is
something that the chemical
companies and people that use
basic chemicals don't really
want to have happen because it
increases their accounting
responsibilities and their
reporting responsibilities to
the government.
It included a hazardous waste
land disposal ban.
And this is kind of
interesting, because there are
about 300,000 community
landfills sprinkled around the
nation.
Every town has a landfill.
They used to call them dumps,
now they call them sanitary
landfills, which is an oxymoron
if anybody has any sense about
what's happened there.
But for much of history,
people have taken everything
and just piled it up in a
landfill.
And then by about 1950,
they started covering it over
with soil, not thinking about
where the material might go.
I remember when I was young
going to our local
"dump,"
we called it,
with my dad and watching trucks
pull up,
oil trucks pull up and drain
their tanks into the piles of
refuse.
People that would pull up that
were mechanics that worked on
people's heating systems,
and they would use solvents to
take the grease off of
somebody's oil burner.
And that grease and the solvent
would then just be thrown into
the dump.
So that if you dug down beneath
any of these sanitary landfills
today,
you would find not just
solvents and residues of oil and
fuel,
but you'd find many other
chemicals,
as plastics and other products
degrade,
just leaching into the soil and
to underlying water.
So that preventing land
disposal was a very significant
provision back in 1984.
Also, the underground storage
tank program is located in this
statute.
And it requires an inventory
and monitoring of underground
storage tanks.
And you can imagine that
underground storage tanks that
contain gasoline or other fuels
or oils sitting beneath the
surface in a steel tank designed
to last forty years has
contaminated many,
many sites.
Those gas stations that you see
with the yellow ribbons around
them?
They basically are regulated
under this statute.
And they are a product of some
engineer who had the bright
idea,
probably back around 1920 or
1930, that a forty-year life
cycle for a storage tank made
out of steel was going to be an
okay thing.
So what's the life cycle of a
storage barrel,
a fifty-five gallon drum,
for example?
So this design error has
polluted ground water and soil
literally around the world.
And used oils as well,
what happens to that oil that
your mechanic drains out of your
car when you get your oil
changed every 3,000 miles?
Well, it used to be just taken
to the town landfill.
So this statute prevented that
from happening.
So Vieques was like any other
community, it had many of these
landfills, so to speak.
And it was a repository for a
variety of hazardous chemicals.
So key RCRA controversies that
have emerged include the listing
issue, what's hazardous,
mixtures.
If a waste is mixed with
nonhazardous waste,
is it still hazardous?
This has been a debate that has
been intensely litigated with
the idea that dilution is not
the solution.
The idea that motor oils,
some of them are exempted,
even though they're toxic.
That's been the subject of much
litigation.
Household wastes also.
Can they be mixed up with more
hazardous waste?
Mining and oil production
wastes have been excluded.
And one interesting provision
in this case is that corporate
officials can be found guilty of
criminal behavior.
So the standard of evidence for
a criminal case is different
than a civil case,
a civil action,
whereby a civil action would be
decided by a preponderance of
the evidence,
which means that it's more
likely than not that damage was
induced.
But a criminal case demands a
higher burden of proof,
meaning basically that it has
to be demonstrated that a causal
link exists beyond a reasonable
doubt.
And RCRA also,
as I mentioned earlier,
contains a citizen suit
provision.
So by 1986, about 27,000
contaminated sites had been
identified.
And as I mentioned the other
day, now there are more than
300,000 contaminated sites in
the private sector and perhaps
50,000 to 100,000 in the public
sector.
Another statute that is at play
here is the Emergency Planning
and Community Right to Know Act
that's contained in the
Superfund amendments of 1986.
And this basically gave every
community the right to know
about chemicals that are made
by, stored in,
or emitted from local
businesses.
This evolved after many first
responders experienced toxic
reactions to chemicals that were
stored in buildings that were on
fire.
So they went in to put the fire
out and received intensive
exposures.
And it created something called
the Toxic Release Inventory.
The Toxic Release Inventory is
a list of who releases what,
where, and when.
And it has to be provided on an
annual basis to the
Environmental Protection Agency,
but only if the chemical is put
on the list and only if it's
produced or present at a level
that exceeds a certain volume or
weight limit.
So the SARA amendments
authorized additional funds for
National Priority List sites,
mandated public involvement,
provided permanent remedies to
restore sites or to basically
pay for proven damages.
It also requires something
known as best available
technologies to clean up the
site.
So a huge question in all these
cases is once a site is
contaminated,
how should it be restored?
What's the standard for
restoration?
Is it pre-human?
Is it a certain risk-based
standard so that it's okay to
have a little bit of lead or a
little bit of benzene in the
soil or the groundwater or the
trees?
So these are very difficult
questions.
No site is cleaned up back to
its pre-polluted condition
completely, so residues are
always detectible in all of
these cases.
State standards apply if they
are more stringent.
And this is an interesting
provision, because it's one of
the few laws that allows states
to preempt federal standards.
So the Clean Air Act basically
preempts Connecticut,
for example,
from having tougher standards
than the federal government to
emit chemicals to the air.
But unless, and we'll talk
about this in a week or so,
unless Connecticut is out of
compliance with the Clean Air
Act standards,
then we have to meet California
standards,
which are the toughest in the
nation.
So the idea of preemption,
preventing a lower level of
government from passing a law
that is more stringent at the
federal level of government,
is very desirable from the
perspective of the private
sector.
Now, why would that be?
Basically, you'd want kind of a
common ground,
you want to deal with only one
set of regulations rather than
worrying about moving your goods
or your material or whatever it
is,
your service,
across state boundaries and
having to negotiate fifty
different sets of regulations.
So this is a really important
statutory provision that
includes the citizen suit
provisions.
Litigation basically stalled
out RCRA.
And it stalled out Superfund
cleanups during much of the
1980s and 1990s predominately
because of the citizen suit
provision,
it's an interesting thing.
So that potentially responsible
parties would then sue the
government,
claiming that they really were
not the primary responsible
party or that they should pay
only for the proportion of the
material that was hazardous that
was detected on the site.
So the Superfund amendments of
1986 prevented certain forms of
litigation by potentially
responsible parties or parties
that EPA had declared to be
responsible,
and things sped up.
The Vieques story was also
affected by these amendments in
one way,
in that it created the Agency
for Toxic Substance and Disease
Registry,
that's quite a mouthful for a
federal agency.
It sits inside the Centers for
Disease Control,
based in Atlanta,
Georgia.
And this group has the
responsibility to respond to any
community that petitions the
federal government arguing that
they have been damaged,
either their property or their
health has been damaged,
by federal actions that are now
declared to be Superfund sites.
So it allows the citizens of
the nation to basically get
expert scientific advice to
figure out what chemicals are
released and how people might be
exposed and what the hazards
are.
And this agency has played a
really unusual role in that they
very,
very rarely in their history,
now they're twenty-three,
twenty-four years old,
they very rarely have found
that there was conclusive
evidence that the wastes on a
site,
that the hazardous materials
released produced adverse health
effects.
So in 2003, they went down to
Vieques because one of the
islanders petitioned the agency
with this question.
And they went about their
business looking for whether or
not the contaminants in drinking
water might be a problem.
And they concluded no,
the drinking water is okay.
The water comes from a national
forest which is on the mainland
of Puerto Rico,
and it's actually piped six
miles underneath the bay to the
island of Vieques.
They also concluded that now
that the Navy had left the
island that the air quality was
sufficient so that that did not
pose a significant threat to the
community.
They also concluded that the
food that was grown on the
island and the fish that were
caught in the coastal waters
were not contaminated at a level
that posed a significant threat.
So they virtually washed their
hands of this being a
significant threat to human
health.
And they dismissed all of the
claims on the part of the
Vieques residents who believed
that the Navy's behavior and
their contamination caused a
whole array of different kinds
of adverse health effects.
A lawsuit was filed on behalf
of 7,100 residents on the island
in 2007 that claimed that the
Navy was responsible for loss of
health.
And the government's response
has been really quite
interesting.
In one respect,
they responded that well,
they are protected by sovereign
immunity,
which basically is an argument
that the king is immune from any
litigation,
that the king should not be
held accountable for past
behavior.
They also argued that bringing
a class action lawsuit
representing a large group of
people like this but focusing in
on a representative sample of
that group so that you wouldn't
have to litigate and develop
evidence for each individual
among the 7,100.
The Justice Department believed
that this should be handled case
by case.
Now, here's a community that is
well, well below the national
poverty level.
They had no resources to mount
a case like this.
So that several law firms have
picked this up.
And one in particular has been
pursuing Sanchez versus the
United States.
And by some mysterious
coincidence,
there was a convergence of this
lecture and the lecture on
Tuesday and a CNN documentary on
Vieques that was released this
week.
I'm going to play you,
if this works,
I'm going to play you just one
clip from this documentary.
>
Video voiceover:
Nearly forty years ago on
this tiny, remote,
American island of Vieques,
off the coast of Puerto Rico,
a young U.S.
Marine was stationed as a
security guard.
Hermogenes Marrero:
: At age fifty-seven,
this is Sergeant Hermogenes
Marrero now.
He's had colon cancer twice.
He's nearly blind,
and needs an oxygen tank.
He has Lou Gehrig's Disease,
crippling back problems,
and sometimes needs a
wheelchair.
Hermogenes Marrero:
This is where we lived.
This is the actual campsite.
Video voiceover:
Sergeant Marrero says he's
been sick ever since he was
stationed on the island.
Video interviewer:
Yeah, sure.
All the time.
All the time,
because I used to get sick.
I used to get sick, you know?
I'd go out to the firing range,
and sometimes I'd start
bleeding automatically from my
nose.
I said, "My God,
why am I bleeding?"
I come back and maybe I'm
vomiting now.
I used to get diarrhea,
pains in my stomach all the
time, headaches.
I mean, tremendous headaches.
My vision, it used to get
blurry.
Video interviewer:
So what was over there?
Video voiceover:
Today, this decorated
former Marine is the star
witness in a multi-billion
dollar lawsuit.
More than 7,000 residents of
this Caribbean island,
about seventy-five percent of
the people here,
are suing the U.S.
government.
They say what the U.S.
military did here made them
sick.
For nearly six decades,
beginning right after World War
II,
the American island of Vieques
was one of the Navy's largest
firing ranges and weapons
testing sites.
Video interviewer:
Can you give us just a
really detailed picture of what
it was like when they would use
this island as a training
ground?
Hermogenes Marrero:
Inside the base,
you could feel the ground,
the ground moving.
You can hear the concussions.
You could feel it.
If you were on the range,
you could feel it in your
chest.
It would rain,
actually rain bombs.
And this would go on seven days
a week.
John Eaves,
Jr.:  The people need the
truth to understand what is
happening to their bodies.
Video voiceover:
John Eaves,
Jr.
is the attorney in the lawsuit.
John Eaves,
Jr.:  One of the biggest
problems we have is that we
don't believe that the military
has fully come clean with all
the chemicals and the agents
that have been used on this
island.
Like depleted uranium was
denied and then they admitted
it.
Video voiceover:
In my experience in dealing
with hazardous sites and toxic
substances,
Vieques is likely to be one of
the most contaminated sites in
the world.
Video voiceover:
Dr. John Wargo is a Yale
professor who studies the
effects of toxic exposures on
human health.
He believes people on the
island are sick because of the
Navy's bombing range.
John Wargo,
on video:  This
contamination results from the
longevity of the bombing,
the shelling,
the strafing,
and many different compounds
were released,
including lead and mercury and
cadmium,
as well as flame retardants,
fuels,
and many of these were released
in great intensity.
Video voiceover:
: So, do you think this island
made you sick?
Hermogenes Marrero:
: Do you swear to testify the
truth, and nothing but the
truth?
Video voiceover:
: Agent Orange
>
and we used to store it in the
hazardous material area.
It was used in Vieques as a
defoliant for defense line.
Video voiceover:
: This is American territory.
The people that live here are
Americans.
And how do you do something in
your own back yard,
and you hurt someone,
you have to take care of that
person.
And the government's just not
doing anything about it.
>
Prof: All right,
now as you reflect on that,
you should be asking yourself a
whole bunch of questions.
One of them would be,
here's a gentleman who is now
mid-fifties.
He obviously has many different
medical problems.
But he faces a serious burden
of proof of exposure to
chemicals that were released by
the Navy.
So how would you think that
through?
How would you make that
connection?
One question you might ask is,
were the chemicals that they
described in the lawsuit that
were released by the Navy
present in his body?
Well, you know,
the historical reconstruction
problem that I mentioned on
Tuesday is extraordinary.
It's incredibly complex
scientifically and would be very
expensive to document how long
do these chemicals last in
somebody's body?
What are plausible alternative
sources of exposure?
You know, the Navy argued that
heavy metals used in the weapons
were also minerals that had been
driven by winds from Saharan
dust storms across the Pacific
and rained down,
and perhaps that's a route of
exposure.
So the Navy's been very good,
along with the Justice
Department, in developing these
plausible alternative
hypotheses.
Another has been the
ritualistic use of mercury.
Did the mercury come from Navy
switches in the bombs that
leaked out on that site,
made its way into the Marine
food chain,
built up, and then made its way
to the dinner table and into
people's bodies?
Or did it come from an electric
plant that was located on the
island?
Or could it have come from any
fish in the area?
When the Agency for Toxic
Substances and Disease Registry
did their fish sample,
they wandered around the island
sampling fish from many
different locations.
But as I mentioned,
often the sample sizes were
incredibly small,
less than ten in size.
So what you'd want to do is,
you'd want to know that these
chemicals had moved in a
gradient from their location of
release further and further
away.
And you hoped to find a
declining gradient in the
concentration as you moved
further and further away.
But they didn't conduct this
kind of work.
James Porter,
who is the professor at the
University of Georgia that I
mentioned, has done that work.
As you move further and further
away from the bombed area,
you do see these declines.
So key questions that are
raised by this video,
what was the prior knowledge of
the Defense Department?
I know that the Defense
Department had very accurate
records of the ordinance that
was released and where it was
released and when it was
released.
Another key question is,
should this move forward as a
class action lawsuit?
If the courts find that it
cannot, that it has to be judged
individually,
person by person,
there's no hope that this would
be concluded in the next fifty
years.
The idea of sovereign
immunity--should the United
States be responsible?
And this is spoken to quite
clearly in a variety of
environmental statutes that I
described to you just fifteen
minutes ago.
But the central,
core question here is one of
causation.
Did these chemicals cause those
illnesses?
What's the matchup between the
chemicals released,
the chemicals found in people's
bodies,
and what we know medically
about the effects of those
chemicals?
This is very difficult science.
To be held to a standard of
scientific proof,
say ninety-nine percent
confidence that there is this
established cause and effect
relationship would virtually
make it impossible for this
community to recover damages.
Beyond a reasonable doubt,
it's a different matter.
So what you see here is you see
the media getting behind this
case,
being sympathetic,
having a very clear story about
chemical release,
not really knowing where it
went.
Not really fully understanding
what people's exposures were,
how they might have been
exposed via air or water or
food.
But you also have a community
that has lived in an environment
that socially has been seriously
affected.
There is no debate about the
fact that the presence of the
military put the economy of that
island in the freezer for much
of the twentieth century.
And the impact of that in
diminishing their income,
diminishing their access to
basic public services such as
education and healthcare,
such as early detection,
having to travel off the island
when you don't own a car to a
hospital on the mainland of
Puerto Rico is a big
disincentive to get early
medical care.
So late medical care translates
into a higher incidence of
disease and detection when the
illness has progressed to become
more serious,
becomes more difficult to
manage.
Also, everyone is thinking
about "Okay,
what is the cost going to
be?"
What's a likely cost for this
one site?
And remember the figure that I
showed you the other day,
that Congress allocates roughly
two to $2.5 billion dollars per
year for the entire Superfund
program.
Whereas plausibly,
it could take up to a billion
dollars to clean this area and
also to provide sufficient
medical care for the community.
And also remember the fact that
many of these families had
earlier generations that were
plucked up off their property
and moved.
How would you think about
compensating them for their loss
of property value?
Given $25 in 1945 for a tract
of land,
or for the costs incurred by
having your house bulldozed and
having the family move to a
different part of the island.
So it also raises a very
interesting counterpoint to the
Marshall Islands case that we
saw the other week.
And that is that when the
United States decided to take
over the Marshall Islands,
they did so thinking that no
one could survive an attack
there.
They had to move everybody out
of the islands that they bombed.
In this case,
they believed that they could
conduct their weapons testing in
a way that would not harm the
population.
If they concentrated them in
the center of the island and
they bombed the end of the
island, they weren't thinking
ecologically about pathways.
They weren't thinking about
diet.
airborne dust and prevailing
winds.
So that the idea that they
should move the entire
population off the island was
reconsidered.
There are now available
documents demonstrating that
John Kennedy thought very,
very carefully about this.
And Kennedy,
you remember was president
during the Cuban invasion.
And Vieques was a very
important base for staging for
the invasion of Bay of Pigs.
And what Kennedy was thinking
about was okay,
why don't we completely remove
the islanders and resettle them
in other parts of the Caribbean?
He decided against that move.
But that decision perhaps has
come back to haunt the
government, and certainly is
haunting the islanders.
However, this whole mess is a
product of misunderstanding
basic ecological principles,
as well as I think a disregard
for the long-term health of the
community.
There are a couple of other
statutes here that are at play.
And I wanted to bring your
attention to the Wilderness Act
of 1964.
And this statute is quite
interesting in that it defines
wilderness as,
"An area in contrast with
those areas where man and his
own works dominate the
landscape,
is hereby recognized as an area
where the Earth and its
community of life are
untrammeled by man,
where man himself is a visitor
who does not remain."
And it goes on to define
characteristics of an area that
would have to be met before it
could be designated as
wilderness.
But at the same time that the
government left Vieques and
transferred jurisdiction to the
Fish and Wildlife Service to
create a U.S.
Fish and Wildlife Refuge on the
island, Congress decided that it
was also going to declare the
area a federal wilderness.
So it is distinctive in the
United States right now because
it is the only Superfund site,
reserved for the most hazardous
sites in the nation,
that is also declared to be a
wilderness area,
a paradox that maybe you could
explain to me,
especially looking at the site.
The government clearly thought
that it would give them greater
power to exclude people,
which they think they're doing
well by posting signs on the
beach.
This is a sign that is right on
the edge of the water that is
within perhaps a hundred yards
of tanks sitting on a hillside
that became the target for
planes as well as artillery
shells.
So the idea that you could post
a sign and it would keep people
out.
I took a research crew out
there several years ago.
And one afternoon,
there were six or eight large
pleasure boats all lined up
about fifty yards from this
sign.
Kids were out swimming in the
water, playing on the beach.
So the idea that you could
control people via signs,
with no other presence,
it defies explanation.
Another statute that's at play
here is the Endangered Species
Act.
And the purposes of this
statute, passed in 1973,
are to provide a means whereby
the ecosystems upon which
endangered species and
threatened species depend,
may be conserved to provide a
program for their conservation.
So certain types of acts,
including damaging the habitat
of an endangered species,
or taking an endangered species
and either shooting it,
by killing an endangered
species, you are taking it,
under this statute.
So this law,
again, passed back in 1973,
and the U.S.
left the island in 2003,
there were three decades during
which species declared to be
rare or endangered,
particularly the turtles that
lived on the island,
were clearly being affected by
military behavior and maneuvers.
So here's a list of the
species, if any of you happen to
be particularly interested.
So I'm going to have to scoot
ahead here, so we can keep
moving on.
But I wanted you to recognize
that this history of military
action,
of training,
basically testing weapons,
of staging maneuvers that
preceded major military actions,
it's created a legacy of
severely contaminated sites
around the nation.
Here's Johnston Atoll,
which is now the Pacific
Islands National Wildlife
Refuge.
So you see, there actually is a
pattern of taking a former
highly contaminated military
base,
transferring its jurisdiction
into a Fish and Wildlife refuge.
This may look like the
moonscape, but this is the
atomic testing site in Nevada,
where you can see the craters
that are the result of hundreds
of other above ground tests.
Here's another highly
contaminated site in Hanford,
Washington.
The Hanford Works,
the site of the Green Run,
that you could read about in
Green Intelligence.
The underground storage tanks,
the same problem that I
mentioned earlier in the
lecture,
leaking radioactive waste that
is highly concentrated into the
Columbia River.
The Columbia River is a habitat
for Pacific salmon and many
other species of fish.
And it's a very highly prized
region.
The military reservation on
Cape Cod provides one more
example.
This reservation has a history
that spanned just about the same
amount of time as Vieques,
from about 1940 to just about
the year 2000,2001 actually.
The jets that we're trying to
catch up to on the September 11,
2001, hijackers,
they were scuttled from the
Massachusetts military
reservation on Cape Cod.
This site is sitting on sands
and gravels.
And it's basically a collection
of very large aquifers on Cape
Cod,
in which the freshwater sits on
top of underlying saltwater the
closer you get to the ocean.
So that anything put on the
surface will drain into
underlying sands and aquifers
moving very quickly.
So this has become the largest
drinking water contamination
site and remediation site in the
United States now.
They drilled some 8,000
different wells to try to figure
out where the fuels,
the flame retardants,
the munitions residues,
the TNT and RDX,
etc., where did it go?
And they've monitored it out,
and they created these plumes
that pump the water up,
out of that aquifer and then
into these charcoal tanks,
activated carbon tanks,
some of which are bigger than
this entire lecture hall.
So day after day,
twenty-four hours a day,
decade for decade,
this water is pumping through
there,
hoping that it will be cleaned
up to meet the Safe Drinking
Water Act standards by the year
2035.
Three thousand pounds of
solvents have been removed from
that water.
One thousand pounds of fuels
was removed from the
groundwater.
And eight plumes are now
undergoing treatment and
remediation.
This is immediately adjacent to
a variety of cranberry bogs,
so cranberry farmers bore the
brunt of economic loss when this
was discovered.
So critical lessons here about
Vieques, knowledge is power,
that's very clear.
Classified information prevents
the public from understanding
what was done,
when and where,
what the nature of surrounding
or nearby community threats
might be.
A question of who conducts the
science.
It's clear that the ATSDR who
are within the Centers from
Disease Control,
was not doing high quality
science and came to a premature
conclusion of safety based upon
a highly limited sampling.
Science normally proves no
causal relation.
So this type of science is
perhaps one of the more complex
that I could imagine.
Also one lesson here that is
apparent is that new evidence of
risky behavior generates a very
defensive attitude on the part
of government.
So any information that they
release, any studies that they
conduct, could increase their
liability.
So often the response is
"Well, then let's just not
study it."
Okay.
I'm going to pause there,
and just wish you a great
weekend.